[Music]
order night
hello what's up
I'm d-bag just get it over with what
your character that somehow ties into
the review and you're gonna make my life
a living hell so just get over with what
are you talking about I'm just your
everyday 90 student a-hole I knew it and
you're on your way home for Christmas
aren't you
how'd you know because you're the visual
representation of why everybody wants to
love assholes like in today's movie but
everybody does love assholes it's cool
to be hated well just say your
catchphrase is for the trailer and we
could get on with our lives well I did
have quite a few but screw it I'm coming
to your place for Christmas what don't
do that
yeah you just need some time shag with
the d-bag no please even a Cammy always
to my heading over right now wait what
do I care if you even know where I love
I don't but my nerdy sidekick I
constantly bully does according to my
machines at beep it's definitely
precisely
yeah thanks geek now I'll give you back
your pet hamster Ally oh god I'm
charming I'll see you soon critic no you
stay there you're watching trademark it
is true we have a fascination with jerks
perhaps because they do and say what we
want to do and say but don't because we
have too much of a conscience
jerks dick lunches and buttholes have
been popular for years whether we boo
them as the antagonist laugh at them as
the losers even cheer them on because we
find that shred of humanity that we
inspiringly connect to and then there's
jerks who have none of that but where I
candy for tween girls so we gave them a
holiday movie
Jonathan Taylor Thomas or jtt as I've
refused to call him then and proudly
refuse to call him now was a bit of a
heartthrob for a short amount of time
acting as the middle child and home
improvement Thomas left his hit series
to pursue a career in movies resulting
in I think movies yeah most of them
didn't do very well but the one many
claim to be his crowning achievement of
all is Disney's I'll be home for
Christmas
appearing on many worst Christmas movies
effortless this film suggests it's fine
to be kind and generous to others but
first you got to ask what am I gonna get
in return
well definitely not ticket sales as this
film bomb so bad they haven't even
released a blu-ray of it and keep in
mind this is a world that allows this to
have a blu-ray but we have a habit of
looking at the worst of the worst so why
break Christmas tradition let's take a
look at what nobody put on their resume
so we start off I'll be home for
Christmas with its matching song
Steve Allen's cool you'll hey what do
you know that doesn't fit that that
doesn't fit just as you're waiting for
Moon Man to appear the film opens in
highschool
University where our main character Jake
played by Thomas agrees to let his nerdy
friend Ian out of his locker if he gets
him his math test answers and backstage
passes to Dave Matthews Band let me out
to get my mail math test words can't
explain how excited I am to be
cinematically manacled to this prick he
wants to meet his girlfriend at her dorm
room but for some reason her roommate
won't let him in maybe she saw man of
the house unless what's this
cherry crunch
the classic girls like cherry Crunch
Bars joke shoo-shoo
she's dating a freshly escaped from 7th
heaven Jessica Biel who tries to turn
down Jake's charm and by charm I mean
tilting his head back like his eyes are
in his nostrils you can even see him
doing it through the back of his head
looks like it's snowing he also wanted
to tell her that snowing outside but
it's just another one of his hockey
schemes
oh hey Ian oh yeah he said they wanted
someone less attractive than Jonathan
Taylor Thomas in fact I think that's
actually how I'm credited in the cast he
offers her a trip together to spend
Christmas on a beach but she's angry
because she wants to spend it with her
family
his forces Jane to confront this weird
sensation humans call emotion my mom and
dad would be crushed if I didn't come
home what about your dad which one I'm
ditching two at the moment Wilkinson
residents personal man-slave speaking
Jake gee dad look Jake I'm calling to
find out about you are you uh still
planning on coming home for Christmas if
you could cast me in a different movie
that'd be great
you haven't been home for the holiday
since mom died I think it's time that we
become a family again
I know it's difficult but the mouse just
doesn't like mommies I stand a mother on
the phone
no no just just just adolescent going
through an arc
[Music]
he's dad sister and stepmom all say they
wanted to come home but because liking a
character is so lame he still says no I
just really want you home huh well I
just don't think I can get there not
even if I give you the Porsche excuse me
yep you're hearing this right folks our
main character is going home for
Christmas because of a bribe if you're
home by the time we sit down to dinner
six o'clock Christmas Eve the car is
yours great bye you are mine oh mine
hey mr. Grinch what are you doing here I
just wanted to say this guy's an asshole
yeah yeah he's pretty been such an
asshole this of course raises some
quickly ignored concerns he cashes in
the tickets and you offer him a bribe
you see anything wrong with this picture
yeah yeah I do
but Jake's coming home for Christmas
best ad of the year or best dad of
all-time or fucking enabler you pick but
that also doesn't stop him from Mickey
look like he's going home to see his
family in front of his girlfriend but it
gets even better it looks like her
family also happens to live in the exact
same neighborhood as his I'm so glad
they both got accepted to the same
out-of-state college that they both
apply for after high school but what can
I say
dickhole university is pretty popular
Minnie screech pages the correct answers
to a bunch of jacks Jake promised to
help as you know the teachers totally
fine with pages being used during a test
sorry miss Peterson coach likes to stay
in touch well with an airtight excuse
like that I have no choice but to accept
your reality but another douche who has
the hots for Jake's girlfriend
yeah let's just calm douche too because
there's really no difference between
them they come in the same box stops
Minnie screech from giving the answers
causing them to fail the test resulting
in him being locked in his locker
32:14 we never see him again in this
movie so I'll just assume he died
meanwhile during your traditional
college Christmas party with rave music
drinks and public domain cartoons for
toddlers hey everybody quiet down the
suckers plain rude on
Jake talks about how excited he is to be
with his car like it knows you and it's
listening and just responding unlike
people god I hate those things
but the jacks catch up and what to make
him pay for causing them to fail so they
drop him off in the middle of the desert
and a Santa outfit they glued to its
body um is this a prank or attempted
murder I'm pretty sure this was fall
under attempted murder which for this
character I'm totally fine with hello
minor setback critic I tried cheating
some guys and they stranded me on the
side of the road Trust is the Easter
Bunny why did they dress you as the
Easter Bunny I don't know quirky well at
least you learned a valuable lesson
he'll know I have a ton of other schemes
in mine to get home while screwing
people over what in fact I practically
blackmailed my family lied to my
girlfriend and left my geeky best friend
in a horrendous situation all before
leaving happy no idea how this happened
I just like ibly hateable look you seem
to be wired to hurt anyone you come in
contact with just turn around go home to
your family no can do
there's so much more despicable miss to
spread oh hey the car that says puppies
were sick kids is pulling over
gotta go no driver don't make eye
contact so Jake is stuck in the desert
with literal vultures following him I
[Applause]
said I wished I were dead
I came to pick off what's left of your
talent yeah I found nothing
no look Frankie Muniz was dropped off a
mile down
sit okay this movie might redeem itself
if the rest of it is just a roadtrip
comedy with the vulture he's already the
best actor in the flick I'm sure they
trained him a lot better than they did
Thomas died so that leaves B would
douche too to get a ride with because
surprise surprise he also lives in the
exact same neighborhood again dickhole
University keeping people asshats but
close just the two of us riding the
crest of Destiny's rainbow first the
ground rules if you say too many stupid
things like that I'll have to slug you
if you make me listen to any sexist
racist or homophobic jokes I'm gonna
have to slug you wait the new disclaimer
for youtube comment seems pretty harsh
so Jay calls his family to tell them
what's going on when did I become your
slave the day you were born
oh right Oh dad well she seemed
bizarrely accepting of that I just
assumed anyone born after Jonathan
Taylor Thomas was a forgotten pawn his
father big shock doesn't believe him so
he manipulates an old lady to give him a
lift he's so worried about the operation
not thinking clearly Oh family chip
standing on a triple bypass for
Christmas Sonny are you trying to be
funny
no I'm serious are you trying to be
funny none of these jokes are landing it
on I said home every last dollar I
earned working as a shopping mall Santa
yeah bridge is no Christmas Eve my god
is this bit dying I don't know there's
anything we can do the same no I won't
be home until after the anesthesia
withers up no I will not let you take
this joke clear clear
[Music]
a lot of death in 2016
he gets a lift but it's not very long as
what woman's teeth falls out the Tom
Jones music is too loud pickles are
spilled all over amend I don't know
prune juice Wheel of Fortune being
racist about something the old prison
cliche bag has it all never heard us are
tougher so he walks to a nearby
Christmas attraction to spend the night
ooo dubby secret fat man handshake I
ride you know confidentially speaking
just between us Santa's don't you ever
get tired of wearing this suit I mean
every year it's the same suit red red
red red red I mean this honey guy really
looked good in red
I don't think so uh John none of this is
in the script yeah I know I just I do
Lily improvising please don't he wakes
up the next morning they'll define
something unexpected
wake up chief time to feed the reindeer
okay can we play my heart's reaction to
that scene we just saw time to feed the
reindeer yeah that stopped that stopped
right in its tracks if we could avoid
more scary imagery like that the main
character is scary enough already
oh it's nothing bad on you act like
you've never slept outside next to a
statue of Santa who suddenly came alive
because of an illegal substance what I
didn't say that huh you know Chester
where have you been I barely see you do
any bum reviews anymore the way a bean
occupy waking up next to statues of
Santa brightly what do I pay you for you
don't
I'm just allowed to be an award for
building which I am very thankful for it
if you're not doing a book review how
come you're set up like you're doing a
bum review I dunno it just kind of
thought this is how you like to talk to
people yeah well and don't come back
until you do another review but I make
you cry you'll be occupied with my foot
up your ass so please not like you guys
Christmas so he then gets a ride from
will to be frank not a bad actor but a
fascinatingly bad actor I mean it this
guy should be studied hey y'all can talk
comic oh man I have never been happy to
answer that question in my life did
tommy was so breed it's kind of amazing
nothing this driver says sounds of this
world
rot in a state
facilitate Oh No I went and killed Santa
he sounds like a human you buy at the
store and grows to life size after you
place him in water
Oh sugar doll I won't if you don't want
me to heavy I have no idea what
dimension would accept this as typical
human speech as part of the same
dimension that accepts this man ah
unholy meanwhile Buell continues her
adventures with douche - look I'm a
millennial type of guy a medium - ten
points for possibly giving birth to the
term millennial I did world music I
think freon should be banned
what does Jake have that I haven't got
no seriously we are written as the exact
same character I literally don't know
the difference between us amazing things
things that just give me the chills you
know the same way a serial killer gives
you the chills by the way here's a fun
game count how many times are background
changes in between shots
[Music]
hey if this rain will be home by seven
nine and twelve o'clock but in yet
another co-inky-dink their car passes
Jax are you saying that's mrs. Claus in
that car with another guy mrs. Claus
stepping out on Stanton Lynch the mother
guy down the chimney while that two time
at hope there's corpses in the backseat
of the van I just know it they try
catching up but they're caught by a cop
for speeding Jake tells the caf's
handing out toys to the Children's
Hospital which of course results in the
officer is courting him there and even
walking in to see him give the goods in
the van out to the kids there's even a
little boy who stilted acting moves them
to tears what do you want for christmas
to go home I want to be with me mama me
papa me hermano Marybel near mono Mario
and not to be seen as the worst actor in
the movie Christmas carols
oh thank you cutting to him will help I
don't want to fence stolen goods no more
I just want to thank you to come home
for Christmas
yeah I gotta call you back I think the
guy next to me said something about
stolen goods even Jake calls home but
don't shoot it's a stepmom that doesn't
count
where are you now are you on your way
home yeah look I got a run so you take
care now okay okay bye you sure the
original title wasn't I'll be horrible
for Christmas as the driver decides to
go back home the cop has a bit of a
confession that's my wife
Marjorie she left me last month and well
if I could just get her back home for
Christmas I know we could start again
why are you telling me this she won't
listen to me but I got a hunch you might
listen to Santa so this is what happens
when a movie is written entirely by your
toes your idiotic despicably
mean-spirited toes but of course it's on
the way to where it needs to go so
what's the matter with you man you love
her enough to marry her which won't take
a little drawing if I could put that
face on a dartboard add four flaming
punches at it I've been an all hooky who
watched this movie good news critic I
stole a car that's progress I also ran
into the sick kid
who said he just wanted to go home for
Christmas yeah you know I felt bad like
really bad that he wasn't able to go to
that beautiful place he called home so
you stayed with them until his problem
was solved nope I burned his house down
that way you don't have to worry about
anymore isn't it adorable how much
you're not supposed to like me I am
trying to be so patient with you but you
are not making that easy I know I guess
I'm complex see you in a bit pray for
everyone everywhere
[Music]
hey everybody quick update you're
actually getting a review early next
week you have a review this week and
then you have another review next week
of rogue loan with Chris Duckman it's
going to be really really cool and after
that it's going to be an editorial
they're reviewing an editorial and so
forth so that's going to be the new
schedule the only downside is next week
because of Christmas schedules and stuff
we won't be able to get on channel
awesome calm a day early on Tuesday
it'll still be on YouTube on Wednesday
but we're not going to be able to get
done by that Tuesday so I'm so sorry all
the other times you'll still be able to
see it a day early channel awesome can
there's a one time but you know it's
Christmas schedules and stuff like that
so uh just redo it again next week you
get another review you give review of
rogue one so definitely tune in for that
and hopefully we'll see you there back
to the show
so while waiting for Jake to come home
his dad polishes the Porsche he promised
him there is not an obstacle in this
world that will keep my son from this
car oh my god there's a scratch to the
scrap where where
Ketel wife dad but it's nice to know you
care more about the car and Jake and
your daughter and your wife can I get a
car seeing how jake proclaimed you as
his slave I don't think he would like
that this is a good family so Jake goes
to the restaurant and tries to win the
cops wife back after he kissed that
Tramp in front of everybody at Smitty's
well you know I'm sure it was a friendly
kiss right like brothers sister you know
the kind you see in Folgers commercials
but a country band drives by and
completely off-screen Jake convinces
them to play for the cop to sing a song
in order to win her back
Oh Marjorie Oh Marjorie
no no I'm sorry you need to show how
that back and forth went if a kid in a
Santa suit said hey this cop you never
met cheated on his wife play for us I
think I would ask him if there was dirt
in my nail
Oh
Hey look he's writing the script in
front of us suddenly this movie is
adding up a lot more
Oh baby
baby
I'm not trying this one so with one
couple founded on adultery happy let's
see if we can make another couple
founded on adultery happy yeah I guess
you couldn't tell the difference between
douche one and douche to either I'll
kill her on fine wit for some reason but
him I'll kill him he catches a buzz but
he has to convince the driver to take
him where he saw his girlfriend kissing
so he takes a cooler places an
unrealistic amount of meat some random
person brought on and says it's a liver
that needs to be delivered to where she
is no we need to get to a dobro
Christ why don't you just have it
written in crayon while you're at it oh
my god it's clam it's crap were the
magic markers to credible we're the
color pencils just too realistic
what the hell knows what this crab fall
for quick I'm a pirate ham with a human
heart for a little girl written in white
out that's nothing
I'm a pizza box with a kidney for a
little boyfriend and in dog feces well
you I'm a binder with a human skull for
an octopus written entirely in Braille
it's real of course they all fall for it
because mandus doesn't take a break and
Jake gets to the hotel where they're
staying at I'm assuming cold the
yodeling tweetybird told me if there's
an ally Henderson or an Eddie Taffet
checked in here I'm sorry Santa I'm not
allowed to give out information on our
guests policy does not apply to me I
over ride policy I want to know where my
girlfriend is Do You Know Who I am I was
the kid who was forbidden to sing for
Disney
[Music]
come on could you rough him up a bit
surely you have some spiked wooden clogs
or something but he finds his girlfriend
and she tries to explain herself I saw
you kissing her on TV you dirtbag
he got me under the mistletoe for two
seconds big deal
Your Honor mistletoe law is very clear
on first base adultery they were good no
no no no what was I supposed to do beam
myself home Ally I was stuck in the
desert I couldn't get to you I had no
choice okay forgive you forgive him
first of all there was no apology second
you kissed someone else you're both
awful are cheeks bullshit arguments
contagious but he let slip that he has
to be home by six in order to win the
car why do you have to be home by six
because that's when dinner I'll be ready
oh good can I just watch that on a loop
now that I would proudly play at a
Christmas party so peel ends up leaving
him I care about you you gotta believe
me Santa if you showed up on my doorstep
in a one-horse open sleigh I wouldn't
believe you
can't tell if that's bad for shadowing
or bad humor but we can all agree it's
bad writing you might be a fake
boyfriend Jake but I'll tell you one
thing you're a genuine butthole whoa
that's like the f-bomb in a Disney film
but it's alright because now the real
romance can begin I would have never
thought it ever helped you out after
that Massacre and I just wouldn't be you
me I never thought I'd be driving home
with you either
it does seem impractical even lazy but
from one piece of shit to another we
gotta look out for each other but douche
- changes his mind and drops him off why
because he forgot he's a one-dimensional
character no honestly I'm not even
kidding I'm sorry man I just can't do
that much good stuff for another person
could be way bad for my rep I'm really
trying out for the next demon King movie
to be bully number five
but coincidence number 30 he's dropped
off at a Santa 5k first place gets a
thousand
dollars and last place gets to be an
extra in jingle all the way I'm so torn
I don't want him to get shit but until
he does the movie won't end I couldn't
be written by george RR martin one of
the santa slows down to give him a fair
shot
resulting in jake winning but he finds
out the santa he beat was the mayor and
he usually gives his winnings to feed
the hungry so he drops by his house of
white potato flakes to give it to him
well that's nice
that completely balances out so he tries
every way he can to get back as his
father starts to sulk that he's not
gonna make it even a bribe couldn't get
him home now that's a line I like to
hear in a Christmas movie god bless us
everyone every time a bell rings an
angel gets its wings even a bride
couldn't get him home can't you just
feel the magic what have you done now
I'm gonna rock it ship heading over wait
a rocketship flippers I know has a
rocket ship is Santa Christ yeah I
manipulated him for it uh well we
shouldn't hurt anybody
oh no I still kicked him in the balls
for the hell of it oh why would he kick
me the jingle balls for no reason oh
well let me still get that pizza box to
that little boy that's one of my friends
why are you doing everything you can to
be so awful it's okay I gave pocket
change to a hairless person Oh pennies
from heaven I figured that more than
makes up for it so do you hate me yet
forget coming home just come here before
you do any more damage
will do
I really hope he's not in many episodes
thankfully Jay keeps getting dropped off
at stupid places and he finds a
one-horse open sleigh that he can steal
because compared to everything else he's
done stealing is like a drop in a bucket
fuck you I'm Jonathan Taylor Thomas and
for someone who claims to have little
time he still manages to drop by his
girlfriend's house hey babe see this
one-horse open sleigh it ain't for you
hi
now of course he talks to her and says
he realizes the most important thing in
the world is family so he of course
takes her away from her family to go to
his the thought I guess tell me when
it's after 6:00 okay but I thought she
should just watch watch what my family
watch before I kill them they seem
pretty happy in there without me don't
they
I'll show those bastards I'll run them
all over with my Porsche so of course he
shows up one minute late to prove a very
confusing point but it doesn't matter
because the father gives him the car
anyway what is wrong with this idiot
just a few seconds late yeah deals a
deal and I'm sure it's gonna take us a
bunch more Christmases together to get
all the work yeah thirty or forty at
least wallow to I'll give you two years
dad I'm not running for Jesus
that's the always popular Christmas Eve
parade at night in the back streets of
suburbia plays and our hero is happy
that he did only one nice thing and one
standard thing he should have been doing
for years so buy this film's definition
Christmas Carol would have been a happy
ending if they just stopped at take the
day off because that was both one nice
thing and one standard thing he should
have been doing the whole time the rest
was just filler this movie gets
Christmas
hey yeah I made it I crashed into
several buildings no doubt ruining
hundreds of jobs but I made it and that
makes it okay
oh no I gave another homeless person to
ten hey this isn't change so that
totally makes up for everything yeah you
know it doesn't what does it matter it's
like in the movie it's fun to hate
people it's downright cool oh come on
you know you want to hate me I don't
want to hate you I don't want to hate
anybody come on I've done every possible
thing to piss you off
yeah but I've ruined lives hurt your
friends destroyed jobs I know but so why
don't you hate me because come on I just
what conceivable reason could you have
not to hate me because it's too easy
it's the easiest thing in the world to
do any imbecile can hate it's lazy you
all know what takes effort being nice is
it so hard to be nice to some people but
what am I supposed to do call you a jerk
over and over and over and hope that one
day you'll wake up and go I'm cured
yeah the first million times didn't work
but the millions in one that was the
magic number that's what got through how
likely is that gonna happen and don't
get me wrong there's times when we need
to be angry we need to fight if now we
be goose-stepping our way to work right
now
but it should be one of the last options
not always the first because when you
get angry you don't think straight then
people take advantage of that and maybe
you disagree with me okay fine you know
what I'll listen I'll listen to what you
have to share and even though so much of
what you say feels wrong I'll still keep
it in my mind that you could possibly be
right
because if I'm not willing to change for
you how am I supposed to expect you to
change for me I want to be patient
enough to see more how we're similar
rather than fear how we're different and
you know what it's gonna be hard it's
gonna be so hard I'm gonna fail a lot
hell I failed a lot already but this is
the one thing I'm certain the more I do
it the better I can get at it I may be a
screw-up but I'm tired of being lazy if
you're tired to me we can work on being
screw-ups together
no not today yeah I figured as much you
know what if you ever need to talk we
can talk I think I should just go home
I'm wonderfully disgusting of you good
to see oh the devil was its uncle okay
that makes me feel a little bitter
that's like a pebble clamp against a
tank hey just remember if you ever need
to talk we'll do the important thing
about any character we're supposed to
despise is that they have to connect to
something we relate to whether there's
someone we're supposed to have no
sympathy for or someone we're supposed
to see humanity and something has to be
recognizable because it all comes from
real places and there's no attempt to
understand those real places you lose
the connection this is why the jerk in
this movie doesn't work he's a shell of
what other great jerks were except with
none of the understanding of what made
those characters interesting we're
always supposed to connect whether we're
supposed to like the character or not if
no attempt is made to understand
negativity you'll never be able to give
a direction this is why this goddamn
movie fails especially at understanding
the important things at Christmas
hello mr. McCready I would like to speak
to you for a moment
okay hey yeah
wanted to explain why I've been so
occupied recently all right
you maggot honey
[Music]
I've met sand when mr. McCready this is
due hello I've never been in love before
mr. McCready at least to a human and I
humbly request time to have to spend
with her I don't know how often I'll get
two reviews but I call the time in it
really you've always been nice to me and
I haven't and this clearly means a lot
to you so you know just do it Wendy at
the time if yeah at the time
oh good then we can give you this that
is to say we were going to give you this
regardless of what you said oh you don't
have to do that well the one gave us
quite a bit of money so we add a little
extra yeah but guys you really shouldn't
have do you like it I know I love it oh
oh good did so good well I suppose we
better get going oh wait wait can't stay
a bit oh we don't want to impose or
anything wrong you two are welcome in
here anytime you want
oh um thank you all right let me just
finish up this review real fast
ever see oh okay all right so for you
couch nobody knows what the future holds
but there's two things that are
guaranteed there's going to be a lot of
anger and there's gonna be a lot of
oh right nowyour it's pretty cute you
never you're not even a Bears fan
oh no they always try to eat me in the
for is it use them wisely
[Music]
you
while that to time and ho
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing modest
needs founded in 2002 modest needs as a
nonprofit organization with a unique
mission to responsibly provide
short-term financial assistance to
individuals and families and temporary
crisis who because they're working and
live just above the poverty level are
ineligible for most types of
conventional social assistance but who
also are living one or two lost
paychecks away from the kind of
financial catastrophe that could
eventually lead to homelessness they
also exist to lessen the burden of state
and federal agencies charged with the
care of the truly indigent by doing
everything in their power to stop these
at-risk households from slipping into
that cycle of poverty they promote
compassion and generosity on the part of
individual persons living in the United
States and Canada by standing as a
living testament to the power of human
kindness to change lives no matter how
much or how little a person has to share
if you go to their website you can see
how you can make a big difference so
please click on the link check them out
and see how even a little can go a long
long way
you